hi guys it's silver at again with
another episode of that tutorial kind of
series and I forgot about something I
forgot about this little supports right
here I still needed to add a photo to
that sorry about forgetting that I'm I'm
just really stupid like that very often
again that looks like a centerpiece
certain extent can't get that over my
head
mmm something I forgot to mention as
well but it's pretty obvious is that at
this point usually you'll have a
concrete base of the support so just
take a gray color for the base for
example and then this with all the bolts
and the thing that actually I don't even
know what used to call that thing that
one iron thing that connects the the
photo to the supports usually has the
same color as the support I think always
has the same color as the supports but
anyway we need to do something I forgot
about the catwalks so need to do that
real quick just this is just going to be
a little yeah what should I call it just
just stop finishing touches I guess to
the coaster itself so we're going to
open gary roaches B&M catwalks which is
a set in french which is awesome but
it's it's you can work with this it's
not too bad plus I'm not even going to
try to actually pronounce these things
because I know in my my French
pronunciation is not not too good but
you once you get the hang of it this is
a actually pretty easy to use set
especially since he doesn't have exact
thought i conce for every scenario
objects but he does have icons for that
being um sit down and some for the wing
rider and for the invert so you can kind
of recognize the pieces and we need
one of these pieces for this let's see
wait what
Oh eater need to turn it around so
that's great I think that I'll be enough
but you can also add some catwalks for
the pre drop I'm just going to do that I
guess
should I do that I guess I can coasters
don't always have catwalks on the pre
drop I'm not entirely sure about doing
this actually we do they or do they not
have when it's a big feature up I know
they don't use it but sometimes you have
a very little small dip yeah you know
what you I'll just leave it out because
I'm pretty sure there are some coasters
without catwalks on the pre drop now we
do of course need some straight cut
walks on this thing and I'll explain the
catwalks about the about the break run
later on because this is something you
need to add to them but I'll get to that
later on for now you just you'll just
have to use some straight pieces and one
piece and the one piece anime yeh one
piece is a special piece which is son
the full command before Ava I'm not even
going to try to pronounce this word
right so you have that piece with with
the little gap in it that is so
basically I see so many people doing
this for their left hills and then
leaving it at that and it's like what
what is even the point of this catwalk
like how are you going to do anything
with this the point of a catwalk is that
in case the coaster really sucks and
decides to break down that somebody can
at least go up and either repair
something or if people are stuck on the
lift hill for example that they can
evacuate the guests so they can get off
the ride mmm
which is why you need to add one of
these evacuations but evacuation things
and I just see that I messed up because
the ground underneath your evacuate
evacuation thing has to at least be
well ground I guess you can't just
evacuate people into the lake here so
I'm going to have to move that one let's
see mmm I guess I can place your there's
support in the way here so you also
don't want the support to interfere with
this so this this seems like the best
spot to do it and then what you do is
you're going to open the different part
of these the catwalk the evacuation and
oh my god I was III I won't do that
again
so you open at Lafayette Road you open
that and first you need to find one of
these one of these many interesting
pieces that somehow can connect the
stairs to this thing I'm just going to
place the stairs first because I have no
idea how to do this
I still don't because this sack can be
really annoying at times yeah and as you
can see it doesn't it doesn't really
connect with that so Oh God
let's see I can do it like this but that
means I'll have to find some pieces to
connect it which is going to be quite
annoying Wow it's doable let's see and
now we just need a quarter piece for the
end here alright so that's a beautiful
staircase now all we still need to do is
connect it to the thing and then and
this is the annoying part so let's see
this wait the staircase and a little bit
lower than the catwalk so I need to find
a little stir
let's see nope that's not working
oh that's inverts oh wait oh wait never
mind never mind about this totally
messed up right there I need to I need a
different piece got the wrong piece I
got the piece that turns to the left but
I probably need the piece that turns to
the right and let's see it should be
okay okay okay if we're going to do it
like this I'll do that then
I've got down this set so annoying well
it's great though the models are great
so I'm not gonna complain about that
it's two sides its user friendliness you
know it's a thing too that you might
want to think about when you're making
custom scenery sets for all your custom
scenery set creators out there I'm in
the middle of the process of actually
translating my own set because it's
currently in Dutch and of course you
don't
many people don't understand that I
don't understand it either sweet
language to be honest and so now we need
one of these quarter patches we can add
railings later on and this quarter patch
doesn't seem to want to work let's see
okay that and now we just need to find a
few small railings and then it should be
good Oh are we I don't bother we come on
this is this is not working can you not
can you not please this is a half one I
need a quarter one okay okay we're
getting somewhere we're getting
somewhere
no I guess I need this piece oh no it's
still not good still not good there we
go I think that's it
yeah perfect so that's the staircase so
that's great
catwalks are done wait no catwalks on
finished yet I probably want to add some
catwalks to this it right here and let's
see because that's going to be
I can't do anything about that
basically you've got a coaster nets and
these coaster nets run underneath the
track when the track is going over a
pathway so for example I've got a track
going over the path here then I need
some coaster nets underneath the track
so about things that fall out over the
tray car wait that doesn't happen so
that people can't throw things on the
track or something like that so that
dangerous situations don't happen
basically now there aren't any coaster
nets for these kind of pieces I think so
and that's going to be hard so just
forget about that so I'll just leave the
queue open like this oh there's no other
way because I'm pretty sure there aren't
pieces for this I can always check out
I'll just check real quick but I don't
think there is I know one coaster set
piece
let's see these coaster nets but yeah
they don't they don't quite have
diagonals like this so nope so that's
not very handy I might someone needs to
make a coaster that set just realize
that but anyway I need still needed to
finish the station didn't I so yeah
let's see if I actually finished that
little roof piece I don't think I did
nope need to add some eaves so just
going to do that real quick I mean the
shingle roofs pretty awesome set let's
see all you need to do is just use a
straight piece straight half piece
lightly
probably did on the sides as well yeah I
did with a bluish color on top white
underneath that
oh oh oh this is not very handy this is
not a perfect situation see if this
actually works it does actually kind of
seem to wait no do I see you I see the
yes I see it okay
basically what you never want in any any
roller coaster or I mean custom scenery
is that it intersects and then you've
got these weird glitching textures
that's kind of one of my pet peeves and
while I go cycling three so don't don't
have to do that I am NOT a big fan of
this roof this is not looking good and
of course you've got these diagonal
pieces but no quarter diagonal pieces so
there's no way to fix this actually so I
guess I'll just have to deal with this
then though I might also just deal with
the intersecting no that's probably even
worse oh well
they look too bad
I mean it could be worse
let's see and how did I mess up there
are just this others
Oh what is what is this even oh I see oh
I see I needed to use a diagonal piece
of course stupid I'm so stupid
now these I ignore pieces always confuse
me so I'm sorry if I oh wait I think I
already got it right never mind
that went better than expected okay so
that's the roof all done I just need to
add some walls and like people said I
need to add more windows / details on
right here and there totally right
need to add some shadows two windows
always need to add shadows and always
need to add dormers if your building is
kind of bland and boring just add as
many dormers or windows or whatever as
you can because that's going to make
even a stupid building look a lot better
now if I remember correctly these roofs
are 2h so I'm going to have to open
shyguys alpine village set 3 wait does
that have to h in it it should yeah
there we go
shy guys sets by the way you always have
to mix them it's never a good idea to
get just one of them it's it's the best
idea to get all of them in one go since
they all kind of yeah basically how
should I put it
sometimes you've got sets which don't
even have war pieces and you need to use
the wall pieces from other sets for
example this is the case with water
world you're expected to use the walls
from shyguys alpine village and stuff
like that it's more like one big set
that's been categorized into multiple
groups by shyguy then a bunch of
different sets with different kind of
pieces this does though make a very good
combination of sets too
mix so that's pretty cool plus you've
got a great variation of various pieces
starts pretty cool as well Oh messed up
the placement right there already
thought something was wrong with that
I'm getting tired of this I'm just going
to use shift
I guess wait why does this thing knots
Oh totally forgot about that
I need them to intersect okay yeah lots
better don't really mind about these
white walls having a textured list
glitch because it's really hard to
notice when white walls have a texture
glitch just because they're all white
and stuff they don't really have a
texture so that doesn't really matter
not all I need is a 1h wall and I don't
think that's in this set so I'm going to
have to open shyguys alpine village 1
and lower that great I think I messed up
on that means have to clean that up
later if I I don't forget about that and
of course I kind of want to have a
window well I'm not sure what kind of
window I hope there's something good in
what a what set
what a world set by the way is great for
any generic building because it's got
those generic kind of windows and stuff
and also generic kind of tropical roofs
that I don't like to use for generic
non-tropical coasters but they're pretty
cool for tropical coasters I think Murph
the engineer uses them quite often and
let's see ah good enough probably going
to add something to decide today because
they're looking a bit empty and now all
I need to do is probably add some
shutters let's see if I can find them
y'all there they are no I guess Brown it
would be an okay color but I'm not sure
yeah that's good enough good enough for
me
you see shutters make windows look a lot
better it's not too much of work but
it's kind of an easy thing to make
something like better
just like dominoes in a way something
easy I can help you make your buildings
look good and and now I know I know I've
left out these squares there's nothing
in these and I've no clear while I'm
going to add in them but I felt like if
I add windows all around it would be too
repetitive so I might add something else
in there these are also pretty cool hmm
came at both or is that weird because
this looks pretty cool I mean they're
both they're both shutters but you know
what that's probably too much just going
to leave that out then and let me just
see if there's anything else in this
that that I can use doesn't seem like
that no this should do I should do for
now
I can always add some more details to
the station later on okay so I think
that's no no no not yet not yet still
need to add some catwalks stupid me and
maybe I'm going to add a transfer track
in the end that might just happen but
just for now I'm just going to add some
catwalks here beautiful beautiful love
the Sun
and yeah that should be good
great so we've got all the coasts of
goodies done I think yeah we've got the
what do you what do you call a fallback
thing on this rack we've got the
catwalks we've got the chain lift return
and everything else so I guess that's
enough for today's episode and in the
next episode I'm going to do the
infamous cue line now I know how many
people always well not always but many
people complain about my cue lines
because I never ever ever put any effort
into it except when their collapse
because I my collab partner does it yeah
always
so this time I'm going to actually have
to focus on the cue line so I hope
that's going to go well oh well I'll
just see in the next episode so till
then